so you have now jumped into and
continued two of the most iconic film
franchises of all time what is something
that stayed consistent in your
filmmaking approach from Logan's dial of
Destiny but then also what is something
about an Indiana Jones movie that called
for something different okay
part a
um I try to bring
my own sense humanist sensibility to the
movie about who this character is and
what they're struggling with that
um whether you're talking about kind of
uh Cape Crusader films or superhero
films like with Wolverine or the X-Men
or you're talking about an Indiana Jones
franchise one thing is true this is a
hero an iconic hero
um each of whom has kind of their own
unique superpowers but what made me make
movies about both these characters and
attracted me to both of them
is they've also got super liabilities
they've got their own flaws they've got
their own regrets
um certainly a similarity between the
two films for me was finding someone at
a point where the shtick they've been
doing isn't working anymore
um the worlds has changed I mean I think
that's even a line in Logan but it would
apply to both movies that you're finding
Indiana Jones in his 70s in a in the
time of modernism rock and roll moon
landings
triangulation Red Scare nuclear fears
um the Vietnam War that's a different
world than the clarity and simplicity of
the 30s of a you know a free world
United fighting Nazis
um it's a very different environment and
similarly finding you know Hugh's
character uh of Logan in a time when of
diminishing returns when his power isn't
as great as it was that to me brings
vulnerability to the character it brings
your journey to the character you know
as long as far back if you want to be an
archaeologist about it is Aristotle
there was this term parippity you know
the Turning of the wheel a story it's
one of the things that people kind of
um have a hard time with when they get
into dialogues online about movies
because a movie isn't a single idea it's
it's it's a peripity it's a turning of
the wheel it's something that starts one
place and ends another so which point in
the movie are you talking about and
um any good story starts someplace where
the character has to travel or grow and
that the for me too often
um for my taste many superhero films
start as gods and end as gods and that
so really all that's happening is a
series of fights and tactical moves
between one set of gods and another and
I don't feel the characters changing
um my and my only problem is it's not a
knock against other movies it's just I
can't make movies like that I wouldn't
know how to so for me I need them to
start one place and get another that was
really important to me in both films
what's different
is that Logan truly was a kind of
tragic Adventure a kind of
um and but also in my own way of looking
at it a kind of beautiful ending for the
character
um of the Wolverine who had never really
experienced peace in his life and in his
final moments Found Love and a kind of
Grace
um even if it was only the last 30
seconds of his life
um that he found that and that he knew
what that tasted and felt like
um to me was really moving
um in Indiana Jones's case I I wasn't uh
first of all ending the character
um but the but beyond that
there's a tonal difference between these
kinds of movies
um and and Indiana Jones is an
entertainment and it's an adventure and
it's got to have joy and humor and crazy
characters and even Indie himself very
different than the grimness that Lo that
Logan represents is a series of
contradictions they can be fussy he can
be demanding he can be cowardly as well
as Brave his punches can have no effect
and Never Land
um so there's a wonderful Beauty a
wonderful set of contradictions to the
character that Harrison and Stephen and
George and Larry kasdin all developed
and that that I wanted to continue but I
had to find at a new age in his 70s
that's such a good answer to that
question now I have to ask because I
really like your approach to doing that
is there another iconic character out
there that you see that same
storytelling opportunity in that you
might want to explore in the future any
movie I do will have to meet that basic
idea just that that the character goes
from one place to another as they show
should as they all should I have to talk
about your collaboration with Harrison
you've worked with some of the best of
the best in this industry what is
something unique to him that he needs
from you as an actor's director but then
also what is something unique that he
gave back to you as a collaborator well
Harrison loves the dialogue with his
director but you know it's interesting
most of the great actors I've worked
with really so superlative actors love
to have a dialogue with the director I
mean a long time ago my second movie I
made with Robert De Niro and he said to
me you know
I need a director talk to me like he
goes I don't work with the young
directors much because they just don't
say much he goes I need this dialogue
and we and we became friends in the
weeks before we made the movie
um just so I understood and I think he
wanted me to be able to kind of
communicate with him and I found that
true whether it's Russell Crowe or
Christian Bale or Harrison Ford or
Angelina Jolie or Winona Ryder or or you
could go on and on
um the the reality for me is is that
the give and take with the director
actually I'm the only audience really
they have so in a sense that that push
and pull a singer-songwriter or a live
performer might have with an audience
I'm kind of responsible for bringing
whatever that response is not just
intellectual but also energy you know
and
um
and I feel that um Harrison in
particular
um one of the unique aspects of him that
I think is really interesting is that
he's always looking to undermine the
tropes of a scene he's always looking
how he can play against the text or play
against the grain a little bit
um it's where all these Great Moments
happen with Indiana Jones that you can't
quite identify
um exactly what's going on but it's him
you know in our movie there's this
moment where he punches mads Mickelson
in the very beginning first reel of the
picture and you know in the script it's
just he opens the door mats is there he
clocks him
um but Harrison goes what if I tried
something like this and he takes off his
hat puts it in front of Matt's face and
then punches him through the Hat there's
no rational reason to do that there's no
there's no audience watching to Indy's
actual awareness although there is of
course so this is purely he's trying to
survive on a train there's no need to
put a felt hat between him and the bunch
but it looks great and it feels absurd
and feels odd but also feels like Indie
and that I can't explain it but he's
always looking for these moments where
he can undermine or manipulate
for our enjoyment the the kind of pure
heroism and turn it into something more
human that's so true between India Han
Solo and even now on shrinking you see
little performance flares like that that
make everything purely I love you I know
I mean the the it is these are these are
him always trying to undermine the kind
of tropes and I think he doesn't there's
not a day I remember seeing him where
he's not flipping through the sides of
the day and puzzling and and puzzling on
how he can just push and pull on it a
little bit that's why he's one of the
best this was not enough time this is a
problem
seriously yes do it you just got the eye
all right I'm gonna ask one of I I
always love asking filmmakers about the
experience of taking and applying notes
versus not and trusting their gut and in
this particular situation you not only
have a whole fan base you're working
with an expert on set and Harrison you
were talking to uh Stephen you have
Studio Executives looking out for the
franchise so can you give me an example
of a note you got from someone somewhere
that you applied and made the movie
better but then also a time when you got
a note said to yourself no my instincts
are on point and you stuck with your gut
the second thing I can't touch because
that would be to be just naming a note I
got from someone and saying but uh but
it happens I mean I've also got all
these wonderful people around me and
they're not always saying the same thing
so sometimes you have a note and the
exact opposite note on your right and
left and you're kind of left to navigate
your way but one of the great notes I
think Stephen offered early on to me as
a very simple tidbit was just this idea
that an Indiana Jones movie in his mind
he realized somewhere along the line
making them is actually a movie trailer
that's two hours long that you that
nothing can sit very long that that the
that any kind of concepts of pace that
you might have about a different movie
have to be kind of exponentially turned
up to 11 on an Indiana Jones movie
accurate you feel it here it serves the
movie well thank you so much appreciate
it appreciate it